hi everyone this is bruno aziza and
today i am talking to
cody now cody's going to talk to us
about real time and anomaly detection
one of the design patterns that we are
delivering to you this week if you
don't remember what design patterns are
in our conversation with robert last
week
on product recommendation these design
patterns are a starting point they're
there to help you
deploy a solution for a given business
problem so
anomaly detection is a big one and cody
has a ton of experience in that
i've known him for a long time he was at
dumbo for seven years and now has been
here at google
for a year so could he take us to the
genesis why does
real time matter to our customers real
time i think it matters to every company
especially this digitally transforming
age
like everything's changing i think 2020
has shown us
like very clearly that companies that
can adapt quickly
to understand customers and to
understand
competitors and the market in general
are those that ultimately win
and we found that real time really is
the solution to help them find answers
quickly so we talked about real time now
how does this real-time problem relate
to
anomaly detection the real-time input
itself is super exciting
like everybody that's like yeah of
course i want real time like
answers fast but the reality is if we
just do real time
if we just take a real time stream and
point it at a company
at a problem it could make things worse
unless there's some
more intelligence built into it so we
found that the sweet spot tends to be
combining real-time data streams with
advanced analytics
so ai ml in this case anomaly detection
so helping organizations find in the
moment
those outliers like the unique things
that they should really care about
and those could be good or bad like it
could be like this is a risk
like worry about this or like hey
something good's happening
this is different do more of this yeah
so we found to be like really sweet
with real time that's why protection is
critical we have to tell people that
these design patterns originate from
customers and partners that tell us
about their need and we go out
use the best practices we have and build
this guidance sample code
architecture guidance so you can use
those best practices at your company so
where did this
story on anomaly detection start on your
end so we had a large teleco provider
approach us and say hey i have this this
problem and originally was actually more
of a processing problem
like we have a lot of data we have this
massive network
we want to know what's like different in
our traffic
but we can't even process the data so we
started there and the awesome thing is
with tools like data flow bigquery we
were able like to meet their scaling
needs
so the requirements were 250 000 events
per second that had to be processed
they kind of kicked off this journey
like we we took that pattern we solved
the problem and we've been kind of like
wrapping it up in a pattern saying okay
does anyone else have this need for
anomaly detection
we've been amazed at how many companies
like yeah
i have a problem i could use some help
it is real time in nature
it really has turned into a kind of a
rinse and repeat that's excellent and
that's that's the whole point for why
we're building these design patterns so
we want to invite you
uh to take advantage of them right now
by clicking on the link down below and
of course
suggesting more design patterns uh that
you might need for your organization but
before we go i want to talk about
partners and how they added to the
ecosystem here and one in particular i
think confluence
that you've been working with tell us
more about that at google cloud we love
love love partners in this case
confluent has been a pretty key partner
helping us
bridge the divide between on-premise or
other clouds to gcp
it's like a lot of times people like
yeah i have this problem i'd love for
google help me solve it
but the process for doing that
integration sometimes isn't super clear
a lot of companies have invested in
kafka confluent is
basically a managed version of kafka and
so they made it very very easy for us to
create that integration and capitalize
on this functionality i will say as well
when it comes to the actual
anomaly detection we found that a number
of other companies have a lot of great
proprietary models that can be plugged
into this so our architecture is
actually somewhat transferable
the pipeline is pretty established like
we know how to do that really really
well
we know how to integrate models i'm kind
of more generic models
but we have partners that really can
augment that and bring
specialty into the actual need so
for some organizations the patterns are
like like the exact solution for others
the architecture's a solution and a
pattern and a model fits really well
into that architecture so there's value
for customers there's value prospects
listening to us
there's value for partners there's value
for everyone again
if you are interested in this design
pattern make sure you click on the link
down below if you are interested in
others that we might not have built yet
don't be shy and suggest which ones
you'd like us to build for you
cody thank you so much for the time
today i hope people can reach out to you
we'll talk to you soon